Now when we did
these calculation,
we saw that the kinetic
energy in the ground frame
was equal to the kinetic energy
in the center of mass frame
plus a constant term, m1
plus m2 times Vcm squared.
And this is a constant
whether you're
in the initial or
the final picture.
So if we look at the
change in kinetic energy
in the ground frame,
that's equal to the change
in kinetic energy in the
center of mass frame.
But this term is a constant.
So there's no
change in that term.
And so we have a crucial
result that the change
in kinetic energy
in the ground frame
is equal to the change
in kinetic energy
in the center of mass frame.
Now let's look at an example
of a collision that's
completely inelastic.
So we have object one.
And it's coming in
with V1 initial.
And object 2, let's
make it at rest.
And afterwards object
1 and 2 stick together.
And they go off with V final.
So here's a collision
in an inelastic frame.
Now in the center of mass frame,
the two objects-- so here's
our lab or ground frame.
I can call it the lab frame
because that one is at rest.
And this is the cm frame.
And there we have V1
prime and V2 prime.
They're both moving.
And now in the
center of mass frame,
they're at rest at the
end of the collision.
So in this collision,
we can analyze it.
And now what I want to
show is that the change
in kinetic energy, recall
from our previous calculation,
that the kinetic energy in
the center of mass frame
was equal to 1/2 mu times the
relative velocity squared.
So remember V1, 2 was
equal to V1 minus V2.
And so the change
in kinetic energy
in the center of mass frame
is the final kinetic energy
is 0 minus 1/2 the kinetic
energy in the initial state.
And what is this
quantity initial?
Well, this was a reference
frame independent concept.
So we can just look
at the lab frame.
And right this as
V1 initial i hat
where that's i hat because
this object is at rest.
And so right away we have that
the change in kinetic energy
is minus 1/2-- now remember
mu was m1 m2 over m1 plus m2
times V1 initial mean squared.
And that's the same change in
kinetic energy as the ground
frame.
So by using our result
here and our result there,
we were able to
very quickly assess
how much kinetic energy is lost
in this inelastic collision.
And where does that
kinetic energy go?
It can go to a variety of
places, deformation of objects.
It can go into sound.
It can go into
thermal energy that
diffuses into the environment.
However, that's how
much is changed.